mais ça va vous s bien passé vous AZ
bien mangé ah tu as mis les bottines
j'ai mis les bot pour les bot de Mir
bien sûr qui passe à toutes les équip
for bravo bravo bravo ça va vous allez
bien très bien je cont de voir je suis
très content d'être là aussi j'ai mais
quand je vous dis j'ai plein de dossiers
j'ai plein de j'en ai tellement que j'en
ai pour la semaine prochaine j'ai plein
de dossiers il s'est passé des bails il
s'est passé plein de bail et il s'est
passé surtout le plus gros prank de
l'histoire de l'indic de laradaac c'est
dans un instant
d'habitud qu'est-ce qu'il a c'est quoi
c'est euh
vous je dis rien on commence par vous cy
non non fais-monous le prank bah je
garde le meilleur pour la fin j'apprends
de vous l'animateur quand je tise oui
vous allez voir incroyable on commence
par vous plutôt avec votre FL par contre
évite de me cracher dessus CUS parce que
là j'ai pris un jacuzzi sur le doigt les
gars là j'ai pris là sans déc on dirait
qu'il m'a jeté un sodo sur le doigt
c'est un truc de
fou ce Doig il y a h maladies
m oh non maîtrise le
geste mais c'est bon alors donc on
commence avec le flair de cy puisque cil
a eu une révélation cette semaine c'est
la révélation de la
[Musique]
semaine r
j'aius non non je sens un bail sens un
bail de quoi un mauvais ba non non je
peux en
parlerine Galine elle voit tout
qu'est-ce que tu as
vu jeis pas je sur un bail vas-y pas bon
arrête genre genre dis entre he rien tu
sais très bien de quoi je veux parler
pas du
tout non je vois pas il est où Raymon ah
c'est ça ba Raymon moard j'en étais
sûr n'est pas là
regarde allez
bâtard
c'est toi ça mais
rig
dansouure
VO on continue avec on continue avecors
je sais pas
c'estroquet de la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Semion imprn par les prestations de il
luiire
film est
bneette mais il était impressionné par
les prestations de mundir il pense à lui
pour un film L'Homme
avisible bon ça y est il a fait la 22
fois il va s'arrêter là quand même c'est
lourd c'est jevec tomomas Longman et il
m'a dit qu' regardé son l'émission et il
m'a dit qu'il était impressionné par les
prestations de M il pense à lui pour un
film l'homme invisible ah le bâtard il
est obligé de finir avec Cyril comme si
on avait pas compris je crois
qu'il regard son les M M' dit qu'il
était impressionné par les prestations
de mundir il pense à lui pour un film
l'homme
j'eme
mon très
bonneonembrasse oh oui toi tu es
vraiment un chien non non j'aime bien je
m'occupe je vais
donner oh oui oh oui très bonne recru
très très bonne recrue mundir puisque
c'est l' REC REC très
très très très bonne recrue mundir
puisquon passe tout de suite au gros dos
on passe au gros dos gros
s je je le découvre avec vous j'étais
sûr que c'était un PR et pourtant on a
pié toute l'équipe on a pié toute
l'équipe cette semaine donc avec mundir
on a créé le prank le plus long de
l'histoire de l'indiic si je vous montre
cette photo
cy c'est r MD humoriste que vous
connaissez évidemment puisquil y a ces
spectacles qui sont souvent diffusés sur
la chaîne fa savoir que Jean avait
peut-être raison au final mundir est un
excellent comédi il a fait croire à
toute l'équipe cyil compris qu'il avait
une idée d'émission alors sur le papier
c'est un peu claqué au sol on va pas se
mentir sauf qu'il était premier degré
enfin il a essayé de faire de montrer
que c'était premier degré oui je vous
explique le concept c'est une émission
de
poker film ok avec mundir en animateur
et Roland mdan en sniper ça donne ce
logo MD ok jquici vous comprenez voilà
okel bâtard quand je vous dis que tout
le monde est tombé dans le piège Gal
sauf moi sauf vous on va voir on
commence d'abord par Géraldine
Géraldine
parumoriste venu jeose pas trop en
parler cy projet le fait ça le titre
c'est
brdd le mec lui dans l'émission C'est un
sniper et MO j'anim est-ce que tu penses
que je
[Musique]
pouris je demand il oui mais il peut
dire oui tu sais parquois pas je trouve
qu'il dit souvent oui et quand c'est oui
c'est non tu vois donc pour le coup je
vais y aller quand même en tout cas
c'est ça SNE comme une évidence sûr que
ça peut cartonner ah ouais l'air
ah et donc là que fait mundir il décide
de prendre son courage à demain et d'en
parler à Cyril cyril est comment dire un
peu dubitatif on
regarde fa que je te parle un truc tu
sais j'ai besoin de toi pour j'ai un
format à vendre vite j'ai absolument
besoin de toi tu sais j'ai un ami à jou
au pocker bon tu connais un mec
s'appelle ronand mcdam bien sûr tu sais
que c'est un ami jeadore ça fait anord
très bon joueur il esttait avec moi en
Belgique j'étais en Belgique là juste et
on a il me dit écoute j'aimerais
beaucoup faire quelque chose avec toi au
poker je dis écoute ça tombe bien j'ai
une émission en tout cas qui qui est en
train de se faire et le titre énergie
les chér minutesour minut c'est 8
millions de joueurs et le titre brûant
MD non arrête c'est marant BR non non
c'est V sur ma vie que ça
Vaur sur la vie de ma mère moi en
tantanimateur plus lui enant sniper Mo
enantimateur Conner
juste c'est
vrai c'est
bon
frère là on est d'accord Cyril pense que
c'est une vanne e frère qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire bah il va voir les chroniqueurs
pour voir si ce qu'ils en pensent quoi
parce qu'il pense que c'est une vanne il
vont il va pas se moquer quand même C il
a un peu d'empathie c'est mal le
connaître je peux faire une émission tu
peux me produire et tout il dit tu
connais Roland mdan tu vois il dit je va
faire une émission sur le poker et ça
serait ché moi je suis animateur il y a
Roland mdan et tout et ça s'aellerait
brand
Magd
parce que moi j'étais sur une émission
de coiffure et poker je te jure que
c'est vrai coiffure et poker ça
s'appelait carré
[Rires]
plongeant il rigole pas je crois qu'ell
a raison oui oui il commence tous à se
demander c'était pas sérieux finalement
non c'est
vrai mais
arrête- il joue pas jou pas mais je
te mais frère j c'est vrai merci belle
équipe
dire vous dire il
est mais mais vous croyez mais vous
savez que je le découvre avec vous vous
nous regardez ce soir en direct je
découvre ce prank avec vous j'étais
encore persuadé que c'était et c'est là
où c'est exceptionnel c'est que là il a
réussi à seer le doute mundir et là les
chroniqueurs et se dire ah merde quand
même parce qu'on se fout de sa gueule
depuis tout à l'heure et c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être vrai du coup les
chroniqueurs s'envent et cyil
aussi d le jeu de ces un
sketch [__] le PO du coup j'ai de la
peine
randd tout simplement j'aime beaucoup
votre amitié j'aime beaucoup c'est pas
une question d'amitié nous on cro que tu
nous charot je te char
pas j'ai entendu votreire à 10
km mer
beaucou c'est vrai tu balanc mais parce
que je croisétait une balle c'est pas
une BAL c'est pas une balle je te don un
truc tu vas leur balancer
laisse-moienvoyer le truc et tu regardes
après si le titre il t'intéresse pas on
change mais j'adore au contraire le
titre c'est ce qu'il y a de
[Applaudissements]
mieuxel
bâtard quand je vous dis que c'est le
prank le plus long de l'histoire des
pranks le lendemain matin mundir fait
genre qu'il est vexé premier degré
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il prend son
téléphone il envoie un SMS à Cyr mais g
en mode très déçu est-ce qu'on peut voir
s pls qui je cite je précise n'a jamais
eu de réponse salut frère je te dérange
jamais mais hier j'étais vraiment vexé
j'ai pas pressé que tu ailles voir
[Rires]
les c'était sincère de ma part je me
suis fait une place tout seul dans le
milieu et j'aurais préféré que tu dises
directement c'est pas bien ou c'est de
la merde plutôt que de moquer de ma
démarche avec les autres tu sais que je
suis franc et ça m'a blessé il é moi
important pour moi de dire c'est énorme
C ne lui a jamais répondu je précise et
là on a déci de boucler la boucle le
lendemain avec la direction de C8 qui
trouve que le projet est incroyable et
qui du coup vient en
parler vra tu vois pas mal
arê
non je sais j'adore
BRD
[Applaudissements]
j'adore
juste avant il m'a dit est-ce que tu
voudrais produire une
émission incroyable c'est magnifique je
regarde pour la semaine prochaine
salut il est très
fort